our community is so giving and caring so
many viewers doing great things all
around town so we've launched this
segment to tell their stories eight
points of community pride
today we're focusing on heroes and
hearts it's a local non-profit
founded by six-year-old justin buma the
organization makes sure deserving people
aren't overlooked
this morning they serve breakfast to a
few dozen culinary workers who have had
a very tough time during the pandemic
many of them were laid off
in addition to the breakfast boomer
wrote individual cards to each worker
and prepared gift bags with his favorite
treats
thank you day as it's being called is
set to become an annual event
he started like raising funds for
single moms to help them diaper they're
young
and so it's just been growing so it's
something that's in him
it's truly something that's in his heart
and it just blesses me to know
that we're growing a generation that has
a heart to serve
that is incredible if you've got a story
of our community coming together please
share it with us
for more information head to our website
8newsnow.com and let us know about all
the incredible things going on in our
community and the wonderful people doing
it i like the name
thank you days that's awesome it is nice